this iPad Pro literally this iPad Pro in
my hands right now holds all of the
secrets to my architectural knowledge
but more importantly it holds one
special document a construction
checklist that literally Reveals All of
My construction Secrets now this is not
something I've shared with you guys in
the past at all not on this YouTube
channel not on social media not anywhere
this is the first time you're going to
get a behind the scenes look at exactly
what is in the construction checklist
what is held behind the pay wall and
best of all two people are going to be
able to download this checklist 100% for
free so be sure to pay attention
throughout this video to find out
exactly what you need to do to win this
digital download but for now let's dive
in to the construction checklist and
showcase everything that you need to
know let's begin today with showing you
exactly how you can get this checklist
first and then we'll dive into exactly
what's inside the checklist as well so
if you want to to grab a copy of the
checklist you jump across to David
toomic.com you head over to the products
page first of all at the bottom there's
three options of this checklist first of
all you have the sketch design checklist
which is a very simple document it only
has a couple pages and it focuses on the
start of an architect's Journey it's a
sketch design checklist very obvious of
course you have the construction
drawings checklist which is what we're
focusing on today it's on the right hand
side of our screen and in the middle you
have the value pack so if if you want to
grab both the sketch design and the
construction drawings for a bargain
price you can grab the value pack but
we're talking about the construction
checklist you just simply jump into that
hit ads cart and download it immediately
if you literally want to try and figure
out what's in this by copying it go for
your life I'm here to give as much free
content as I can this is just here to
save you guys a ton of time if you want
to spend a small amount of money now
let's talk about the actual checklist
itself on the right hand side you'll see
the working drawing checklist it's
designed for any residential job and it
can extend to commercial jobs as well
but it's not recommended cuz it doesn't
go into that much detail we'll start
actually all the way at the bottom we'll
start with Consultants cuz these may be
potentially required in your actual
project you can see there's a series of
Consultants that are generally required
on major architectural projects let's
say you're the architect you can simply
tick that box and it will take a for you
if you need a structural engineer an
electrical a hydraulic potentially a
fire and Energy Efficiency you just go
through that list and tick it one by one
now so many people have asked me why is
this a black document David why is it
not white why can't I print it why can't
I reuse it well the answer is so obvious
you shouldn't be having to print these
things these are digital documents you
should use them on the computer time and
time again and if I make them black
hopefully I'm going to encourage so many
more people to not print these documents
that's why I've called it a negative Doc
think before you print please whatever
we can do do to save a couple trees here
and there let's at least attempt it if
you just download it print it and waste
it it's complete waste of every time
whereas if you actually go through it
online you use it step by step hopefully
you're going to get so much value out of
it now let's jump back up the top and
talk about the side plan the site plan
is the first page that usually comes up
on an architectural set of drawings and
generally we need to have some key
information on that s plan the first
page articulates all of that information
that we need to Showcase so generally
what this checklist is used for is very
simple you're going to complete a set of
architectural construction documentation
and when you go to check it or when
somebody else goes to check it they're
going to need something to cross check
that against and time and time again
you're going to do the same drawings on
repeat but you're going to forget about
all those little details that are truly
required to make a set of architectural
documents good so in this checklist I've
made sure that some of those most common
and most forgotten items are included
all the way through the project project
so on your site plan you want to
actually be able to denote some
important information for example the
plumbing items have you shown all of
your plumbing items have you shown your
toilets your hand basins your kitchens
Etc if you haven't it's probably
unlikely that they're going to be able
to build this properly the first thing
that goes under a concrete slab and
during the actual Earth Works is of
course the pray for the plumbing and the
pray for the electrical so the plumbing
and the electrical items are so critical
to make sure we know where some of those
key elements are going into our actual
project moving down the page you're
going to see the flaw plan now one thing
you'll notice is the scale has actually
changed the floor plan is a minimum 1 to
100 whereas the site plan was a minimum
1 to 200 now this is in metric units of
course it is not in Imperial so 1 to 100
may be completely different in your
America but you can convert that quite
easily on the floor plan you're going to
need a little bit more information than
what you showed on the site plan and we
depict what we need to actually show for
instance room names and dimensions and
annotations we didn't have any of that
previously on the actual site plan we
weren't talking about the floor
coverings the sliding door directions we
weren't talking about those finite
details but we do to talk about them
once we get us the floor plan so hence
why this checklist is going to help
guide you to put the right information
on the right Pages moving on to
elevations and to be honest I'm not
going to run through this entire
checklist otherwise I'm going to give it
all away I want some you guys to
actually enjoy this when you win the
competition stay tuned to find out
exactly how you can actually enter this
competition throughout this video on the
elevations of course there's a few more
different elements that we want to show
for instance do we have any down pipes
and control for instance do we have any
downpipes and control joints on our
actual elevations these things are
critical for the architectural
expression if we don't show it on the
elevation the client might look back and
go I never knew there was going to be a
downpipe right next to my bedroom why
wasn't it articulated why wasn't it
shown it drives me crazy so by showing
it on your elevation you can avoid so
many dramas as you probably already
noticed there's a lot in this
construction checklist and there is so
much that you need to know so you
definitely want a copy of this on hand
on file all the time once you download
it you can use it a million times over
to your own discretion for as many jobs
as you like so if you want to be the
lucky person that wins one of these
checklists I'm going to select two
people from the comments down below
entry is very very simple all you have
to do is comment Keen I and then also
tag your Instagram handle down below as
well at the end of the month I'm going
to select two people at random message
them directly on Instagram with the
construction checklist ready to go so
make sure you comment down below and be
in the running to win this incredible
package this will be the second last
page I Shar with you guys today and it's
the sections page sections are where we
start actually talking about
construction information and of course
how this building is going to come
together in time the sections are
minimum 1 to 50 here in Australia you
can make them even larger if you'd like
to so when we're cutting our section
some things are critically important for
instance the roof pitch have we
articulated that properly the structural
annotations our wall tangs our flashings
our insulation does the Builder know
exactly what our value insulation is
going to that wall do you know exactly
what our value insulation is going to
that wall you could make a critical
error by simply selecting the wrong wall
type and the wrong insulation so many
times have people shown the wrong ey
value in a very small wall and it just
doesn't fit it doesn't work so they're
going to have to beef up that entire
wall it is so much easier to pick that
up with a checklist as you're working
through your construction drawings
rather than making the mistake on site
and costing hundreds of thousands of
dollars so make sure you actually go
through each individual item as best as
you can I'll skip ahead to our
construction details as my final reveal
on this actual document now I've skipped
ahead to construction details because
it's part of the sections we're going to
show small call outs from our sections
on our construction Details page so
anything that is incredibly
architectural incredibly intricate or
something that you want to specifically
get 100% right maybe to Cabinetry detail
maybe it's a Cornus detail God knows
maybe it is as simple as how two floor
connections join how the timber floor
meets the carpet all of these are
important architectural details and we
want to show Construction details to go
with it so when we draw construction
details it's again at a much much larger
scale 1 to 20 minimum if you find that
the call out you've selected is just too
small 1 to 20 blow it up take it to 1 to
5 take it to 1: one it doesn't matter 1
to 20 is a minimum meaning you can pick
whatever you think is realistic and what
is going to help and provide the most
value well we talking about construction
details we're talking about the finer
details you can't see at at 1 to 50 so
for instance scking scking is so thin
most of the time that you will just see
it as a blank line on a massive 1:50
section whereas it 1 to 5 or 1 to 20
you're going to be able to actually
articulate this a lot better same goes
with our flashings of course and our
waterproofing details for our footing
details all of these things can be
articulated in construction details so
much easier than they can be anywhere
else in the documentation package anyway
that is all for me team thank you so
much for watching I hope you enjoyed the
video I hope you got some valuable
content out of this and if you did make
sure you smash that subscribe button
below because we're aiming for 100,000
subscribers by the end of the year it's
a huge huge goal which I literally
cannot achieve without your support so
hit the Subscribe button comment a
friend down below who might be
interested in this channel share it with
anybody you know and help me get to that
Infamous 100,000 like I said that is all
for me so I'll see you next week